you want me to help you move a nuclear
bomb I know the Bose head is pretty hard
but winning this battle may just win us
the war all right give me for 24 hours
not a minute more let's go get our guy
I'm gonna be running ahead of the truck
oh yeah it's our lab so I'll be
monitoring his vitals and I'll be
reciting every prayer that Shields ever
taught me how much time do we have left
if he explodes a good destroy the entire
city everybody it's Charlie we got new
flash to breakdown in Action Comics
1,000 if you didn't know it's a big
anniversary everyone's posting about it
on social media today they hit their
1000th issue
it's Bendis is first Superman issue he's
taking over the title with Gimli so they
did a collection of a bunch of different
stories from all the people that have
worked on Superman comics in the past as
well as a new Bendis Jim Lee story that
lets you know what they're gonna be
doing with the actual comic book after
this big anniversary issue so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a new round of that blast ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video but obviously the big thing with
this next week flash episode is that
they have like the final bus meta that
looks like he's going to be the one to
weaponize Devoe's special enlightenment
device because it kind of looks like a
really small bomb it's powered by dark
matter but maybe it just doesn't blow up
big enough and that's why he needs this
nuclear man to actually turn it into a
real bomb but if you've seen the title
then you know that they're doing Mad Max
fury road because it's called fury rogue
as in rogues like Captain cold for rules
you need to remember make the plan
execute the plan expect the plan to go
off the rails throw away the plan so too
bad heatwave isn't around I'll talk
about Captain cold a little bit too
because this might be what Wirth
Miller's last episode for a long time
because that was kind of the reason they
did that whole earth X thing and then
put them on legends of tomorrow for a
couple episodes it gets really confusing
when you hear that actors are leaving
the TV shows you're like wait a minute
are they leaving this one TV show are
they leaving for good because he's a
flash character even though he was on
legends of tomorrow for a while but I
loved how crazy things have gotten like
they're all sitting there Caitlin's lost
her
our so she's still trying to help out as
Caitlyn because she's still a really
smart biologist she can help out with
these bus Meadows but she doesn't have
her actual killer frost powers it looks
like things are definitely gonna go off
the rails and then Joe
pipes up and says I'm gonna say every
prayer Cecile ever taught me and you're
like wait a minute
is the sealed religious did she actually
teach him prayers are they just saying
her name so that you remember that she's
a character on the show the whole thing
with Cecile and the pregnancy is this
like this big red herring at the moment
I don't know how they're gonna bring it
around at the end of the season I'm in
terror that they might turn coffee-shop
girl into Joe and Cecile's daughter but
I have a feeling that she has some
metahuman DNA in her and they said that
their baby is not a metahuman so it's
like why would they say that their baby
is gonna be a girl and then tease all
this coffee shop girls stuff and then
imply that she's burying Iris's daughter
what is the whole point of Cecile having
a baby on the TV show if it's not
supposed to be some big mislead for a
big fandom payoff like something that
will make you feel very satisfied and it
just doesn't feel like Joe and Cecile
having a baby is gonna accomplish that
goal so it just feels like it's setting
up something bigger be prepared for a
couple left turns I think I said him in
my last episode 18 video that I believe
episode 20 is supposed to be a coffee
shop girl episode so I think that's when
most of the answers will be given but
obviously episode 23 is the finale so I
have a feeling that they'll get a little
bit of help from coffee shop girl that
will lead them into the finale but it's
a little too soon to get all the answers
so just don't expect her to come out and
say this is exactly who I am and this is
what all these Speed Force symbols mean
because remember the Speed Force symbols
is another big thing that we haven't
examined in a long time
we haven't gone back to that since we
saw coffee shop girl scribbling those
same symbols inside jitters at the
beginning of this year a couple months
ago there are a lot of you that have
also noticed that DeVoe has some of the
same symbols on his blackboard way back
before he became the thinker like when
he's still in his regular body here with
his wife before things go crazy easy
conclusion to make is the coffee shop
girl has most of the answers that they
need to defeat DeVoe Barry will have to
use those to put the pieces together and
actually face him himself
but I always love having Captain Cold
back there's a couple things that I
don't like about the affectations that
he
lays on the character like the way he
says some of his dialogue but Wentworth
Miller is a fantastic actor
I love the Captain Cold character so
anytime he comes back it's a lot of fun
but just let me know in the comments how
quickly do you think that the plan is
gonna go off the rails so talking a
little bit about Action Comics like it's
an amazing issue that just honors the
history of Superman like this big
anniversary 1000 issues that's crazy
so what they did is they have a bunch of
different artists from the past that
came back like Dan Jergens a bunch of
other people even Richard Donner and
Geoff Johns came back to do a small
story so it's like a bunch of really
small stories and then like a tag for
Ben disah's story in what the actual
story of Action Comics is gonna be going
forward they did really beautiful covers
of all the different decades of Superman
highlighting some of the big creative
changes from decade to decade so outer
space Martians were really big during
the 50s you have Superman fighting a lot
of aliens
during the 60s everything got really
weird and colorful so you have all these
Kryptonians wearing all this really cool
gear the really cool thing about iconic
characters that have been around for a
long time like Superman and the issue
sort of does this when you look at all
the different covers and the types of
stories is just seeing the way that he's
written and he's drawn to reflect what
the current culture is so within the
stories Superman sort of travels across
time remember when Batman got sent back
in time by Darkseid's Omega beams during
Final Crisis they kind of do a version
of that with Superman
so they can tell stories from different
decades so like there's a 1930s Superman
there's a world war two 1940s Superman
they're all wearing different costumes
they have different power levels quantum
leap styles Superman sort of narrates
the journey like oh wow you know this
seems so familiar but that can't be real
I'm from modern-day how could I be from
the 1930s my powers work a little bit
different and I'm a little bit punchier
than I normally am with regular people
so the issue is really fun even if
you're not a big comic book reader I
recommend you check it out
but obviously really big comic book fans
are all waiting to see what Bendis is
gonna do with the character because this
is the big thing that brought him away
from Marvel that he's been a poor so
long like he was numero uno person at
Marvel Comics for a long time but if
you're not really familiar with what's
going on in comics and that both of the
companies both of them are a little bit
of crisis rebirth was the
for that at DC Comics but part of Bendis
deal is that he gets to consult on some
of the movies as well like he made the
joke that Steven Spielberg's Black Hawk
movie was part of the deal when he came
to DC I told him that they had to get
Spielberg on the Black Hawk movie that
was part of my deal this isn't actually
a thing this is just him making a joke
about it Steven Spielberg was probably
in talks for a long time with Warner
Brothers to do something in the DC
Universe you may have also recently seen
that Bendis separately is working on a
kitty pryde movie with tim miller
obviously x-men Fox Disney owns x-men
right now so you can kind of see that
like Bendis just got everything that he
wanted when he came to DC that was like
part of the lure for him they're like
okay we'll let you work on the DC movies
we'll give you any character to write
you want so he chose Superman but we'll
also let you develop movies at other
rival Studios which is a big thing
usually it's exclusive when big artists
like that go from Studio to studio like
if someone is developing movies at
Marvel for Disney usually you don't hear
about them going across the street to DC
to do a movie Joss Whedon was the first
big one to do that but he left after age
of Ultron a long long time ago so he
hasn't been doing anything at Marvel in
a long long time but just let me know in
the comments what you guys think of
action comics 1000 and what you think
about Bendis taking over the Superman
character with Jim Lee sounds like it's
gonna be really crazy so I'm just
excited to see what they do with it
because they're turning it into a pretty
big high-profile thing they've been
running these Bendis ads for a long time
if you didn't know this is a riff on the
Jack Kirby ad when Jack Kirby came to DC
they were like Kirby is coming because
he was leaving Marvel so it's sort of
like the same thing when you have this
really iconic Marvel creator coming to
DC Comics but obviously there's a whole
bunch of Deadpool infinity war related
stuff happening this week I am working
on a Black Lightning finale video so
while you wait for everything click here
for my flash video from last night and
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight